There was a cat that they recently
discovered,
a prehistoric cat that had this bottom
single tooth and they found out that if
a human skull fit right inside its mouth
and so it could grab you here and Pierce
the back of your skull with its,
with its single tooth and that's what it
was evolved for.
So you know,
it's under such conditions we evolved
and we're predators obviously,
but were tasty predators and so other
things were perfectly happy to eat us.
And so when you're aware you don't know
what to do,
you act like a prey animal and that's
probably what you should do because
maybe if you keep your head down and
shut the hell up,
there will be any attention to attracted
to you and maybe you'll get through it.
You know,
you might decide unlikely to intervene
and take the guy down,
but,
but you would be the exception rather
than the norm.
And it's unsurprising.
Okay.
So what I came to understand was the
belief systems regulated emotions,
but not exactly psychologically like it
isn't exactly.
It isn't.
Exactly.
And this is sort of like the terror
management theories.
It's not exactly like you have a theory
in your head and the theory explains the
world and because of the theory explains
the world.
The theory is what's making you secure.
It's kind of like that.
It's like you have a theory in your head
and the theory makes you feel secure
because it explains the world,
but the reason that explains the world
is because other people have the same
theory in their head and then when you
both act out the theory,
you both get what you want and it's the.
It's the coming together of the theory
and the outcome that makes you.
It's life.
Not only does it stop you from being
anxious and often make you happy because
you get what you want,
but it's not just psychological.
You know,
the fact that we do this,
that we cooperate within our societies.
We match our belief systems and then act
them out.
That's the predicate for a productive
society.
So it's actually,
it isn't just that it saves,
saves you from death,
anxiety,
like the terror management theorists
have it.
It's,
it saves you from death and that's good.
I mean,
being protected from death,
anxiety,
oh good,
that's great too,
man,
but actually not dying.
That's sort of the fundamental thing
that you're after,
and so people have reason to defend
their territory.
If you think of territory that way,
as you think about it as a domain where
the fundamental presuppositions of each
citizen are matched by the behavior of
their coast citizens,
they have every reason to defend that,
and if it falls apart,
it can have mortally serious
consequences.
It's chaos,
you know,
and that chaos doesn't just destabilize
everybody.
Psychologically,
it destabilizes everything.
It can destabilize.
The currency can be stabilized,
the industrial economy.
It can,
the lights can go off.
It's like it's not good,
so hey,
no wonder people protect it.
So then I started thinking about what a
belief system was and I realized that a
belief system was actually a set of
moral guidelines
and moral guidelines are guidelines
about how you should behave.
Also,
how you should perceive and the reason
that a moral guideline is necessary for
you to perceive is that you can't look
at anything without a hierarchy of
value.
Right?
Think about it like how many things in
this room could you look out?
There's an in innumerable things in this
room to look at.
There's just all this squares,
the little tiny squares in this fabric.
You could look at those things for til
the end of time,
one at a time,
but you don't do that.
In fact,
if I took most of you out of this room,
there's a very low probability that
you'll be.
You'd be able to tell me what color the
walls were or even if those things were
on the walls and the reason for that is
that who cares?
As long as the walls don't move,
colors irrelevant and there's no reason
for you to remember it.
It has no emotional significance.
It has no value,
and so what you do instead is,
well,
this is what you're doing,
so why are you here?
I don't mean in the broad metaphysical
sense.
I mean specifically why are you here
right now?
And I would say,
well,
you're a students obviously and you're
trying to get a degree and you know,
you believe that that will have some
functional utility.
Maybe you'll be a little wiser and a
little more literate and a little and be
able to think a little better and be
able to write a little better and so
you'll actually be more functional in
the world.
That would be good.
You know,
and and maybe you're interested in,
but anyways,
it's.
You're in this particular lecture so
that you can take this particular class
so that you can get a particular kind of
degree so that you can launch your life
and then in your life you're probably
going to meet someone that you have a
longterm relationship with and you're
going to have children and you're going
to partake in the society and that's why
you're here.
All of those reasons simultaneously is
why you're here.
And so then that helps you decide what
to look at.
And so what you look at is at the moment
or listened to is me because in
principle,
I'm the gateway to that set of
accomplishments at this moment.
And so you focus on me and that's
because you value that.
And so what that means is you can't even
look at the world without a value
structure.
You know,
it's chaos if everything is equally
unimportant or if everything is equally
important.
It's chaos.
And so value system structures the very
way that you perceive the world.
And I don't mean that metaphysically.
There's plenty of experiments that have
demonstrated that the invisible gorilla
experiment,
which,
how many of you knew about the invisible
gorilla experiment,
how many don't?
Well,
roughly speaking,
what happens is that there are two
teams,
a white team dressed dressed in white
and the team dressed in black and
there's video of them and the black team
is passing the basketball back and forth
and the white team is passing the
basketball back and forth.
And you're supposed to count the Times.
The basket ball gets passed back and
forth.
There's only one basketball.
And so you know,
you're diligent for whatever reason you
do what the experiment or asks you and
you count the basketball tosses and you
think,
well that's not so hard.
It's like 16.
So you tell them 16 and they say,
did you see the gorilla?
And half of you say,
what,
what are you talking about?
And the experimenter says,
well,
let's watch again,
but this time don't count all.
Sure enough,
like 30 seconds into the video.
And you know,
the players fill the video screen.
It's not like they're 300 yards in the
distance,
you know,
like little ants playing basketball
there,
right?
Filling the screen,
you can see their faces.
Sure enough a minute into the video.
This guy in a gorilla suit and he's not
little and neither is the gorilla suit.
He comes out,
bangs his chest right in the middle of
the screen for five seconds and then
disappears and half more than half
actually,
if people don't see that and it's even
worse down.
Simon did another experiment where
you're at a counter,
you know,
at a store and there's a clerk there and
you're talking to the clerk and the
clerk goes down hypothetically to get
something in.
A different clerk pops up and you'd
think,
Hey,
I noticed that,
but you don't.
And you can even vary the clerk quite a
bit and people don't notice.
So we focus on very particular things.
And the reason we don't notice this
because it actually doesn't matter in
terms of the ongoing,
our ongoing action at that point,
the clerk is interchangeable as long as
the entity there acts like a clerk
that's sufficient.
So belief system structure,
your perceptions,
value systems,
we're going to call them systems.
They structure your perceptions and they
also guide your actions because you act
in accordance with your values,
conscious or unconscious.
You have values that you don't know
about because you just don't know
yourself very well.
The you can tell that,
that you have values that you don't know
very well because sometimes you get
attracted to people that you know,
you know perfectly well,
that's a mistake.
Or you know,
you're trying to tell yourself to study
and you don't.
And you know,
so there's,
you're not really in control of yourself
to any great degree.
Some and the more integrated you are,
the more control you have.
But you know,
you're kind of a loose collection of
arguing subpersonalities and they're
more or less directed towards a single
goal.
But it depends on how committed you are
to that goal.
How much you've thought it through,
how much you buy into it,
how many of the contradictions in your
world representation you've managed to
iron out and all of that.
So,
but in any case,
it's value systems that government
action and perception.